We learned about how maps are being used to localized a moving robot.
Here is a laser map being produced--in this case, Stanford's car,
and we used particles to localize this robot
by matching momentary measurements with the previously acquired map.
In doing so we were able to localize Junior in the Darpa Urban Challenge
with centimeter precision.
A similar method is being used by the Google Street View car,
and it is one of the secrets sources of the street-view car.
We heavily rely on a previously built map and a type of localization method
that you implemented to localize the robot and make it follow known lanes.
Here is a localization quiz.
We learned about the 3 filters, Kalman filters, histogram filters in our first class,
and particle filters.
Check the corresponding box if the attribute applies.
If any of those is multimodal in their distributions, please check the box,
exponential in the computation complexity relative to the number of dimensions,
and useful in the context of robotics.
Please check none, any, or all of those boxes.